we were just talking before uh you
walked in about covid
and you had it yes and yeah apparently
you just found out which is i'm like wow
he's so cool i'm just gonna show up yeah
look at him oh my god
i'm almost cleared uh officially i saw
it last night i was going through your
instagram and i saw it i was like oh
he had govind and i freaked out she
phoned me and i go what do you mean he
has kovitz he she you said he has kovid
when did you how did how did it come to
be you're vaccinated yes i i am uh i am
vaccinated i got the pfizer vaccine uh i
was in i was in texas right in the
middle of doing the whole you know
rockstar thing and uh it's crazy because
we had such great uh covet protocols
backstage we had uh contact tracing we
had everybody was being tested everybody
at the show was vaccinated but you know
uh we think that it happened during
press
that's probably so wait you get a test
it was just protocol to get a test or
did you not feel well how did you
discover that you had it well um i went
up on stage uh and i was fine and and
then you know two hours later i wasn't
fine i had chills and i had body aches
and uh it was just like whoa it you know
i've had a million coals but it's one
thing that you know it's gradual this
was from feeling great to not feeling
great in a matter of a really short
period of time and as soon as i got off
the stage i needed a blanket i just
needed to get covered up i was freezing
and i had mean body aches it felt like
like arthritis everywhere and it lasted
for about a day and a half
and then i was fine right
no but so you had the body aches did you
take a test yes i tested immediately and
it was negative and see it doesn't
always hit right away it take it takes a
little while before it shows so you
but you tested when you already had the
body aches i tested during when i was
feeling like crap when i and it came
back negative and then i tested it again
the next day and it was also negative it
wasn't until everything was cleared up
that it came back positive
and that's that's freaky
that is freaky yeah that scares the crap
out of me that's not a good story
so wait so so now you have and it's
funny because i've already had this
conversation with dr king dr ken was
breaking me down he's like dude okay so
talk to me all right so how did it
happen what went down oh i'm sorry uh on
their podcast no no no just in general
you know yeah
but can't help but go doctor on you
you know so wait so so now it's coming
back positive but you feel perfect yes
and then how long does that last like
how often are you getting tested with
this perfect
with like when was the next time you had
a egg how often were you testing after
you've tested possibly after uh after i
came back positive uh then of course you
know go into isolation go on to
quarantine and stuff and then after that
um i i took one test and it came back
inconclusive do you live with other
people uh no i love these
i live with fur babies okay but but on
tour i'm always you know i'm on a tour
bus with a bunch of people so it's like
everybody on the on the bus negative my
assistant who's always with me negative
and so that was it was the craziest
thing that's good news that didn't you
didn't you didn't spill it out no nobody
so now you you test positive you're
feeling perfect and then what is the
next thing next thing is uh like i said
quarantine for uh for a couple weeks i i
did lose the uh sensation of smell so i
could not smell that's sometimes a
positive for a guy that lives in a bus
with a lot of other i'm not gonna lie
that was it was pretty convenient
because we live with three dogs and then
when you're not you've got
your dog's on the bus this one right
here yeah she's a little extra special
sometimes so not being able to smell
wasn't the worst thing in the world but
uh that that was it
but but and then how often did you test
till it came back negative and then how
many negatives you got to wait the two
weeks regardless because you're still
going to be stuck in the house and uh
like i said one test came back
inconclusive and a few days later it was
a you know straight up negative test
so it was a negative test and you
haven't had any symptoms since is your
smell back yeah oh i can smell
i can believe me i can smell okay and
and just for the people at home will you
smell my finger nice yeah
[Music]